ariana grande says she is quote broken
after the terror attack at her concert
which took the lives of many of her
innocent fans and left so many more
injured tonight we have coverage from
around the world Jennifer Paris is in
England at Manchester Arena where this
senseless act took place and nischelle
Turner is outside Madison Square Garden
but we begin with Kevin Frazier and
Hollywood Ken
Nancy today is supposed to be a day of
celebration here in a Hollywood as mega
director Michael Bay is being honored by
putting his hand in footprints here at
the Chinese Theater on Hollywood
Boulevard but of course on everyone's
mind is the horrific attack in
Manchester and so many celebrities
reaching out and sending their
condolences to the victims
I mean I don't have the words for it I
just have the absolute it's devastating
devastating and for the families that
are going through this now this is it's
not even to be discussed it's just to be
pray for them Marcus that's everyone out
there and I am not sure what to feel
today and I'm terrified and I don't know
what to say to my daughter actress Salma
Hayek was at the Cannes Film Festival
when she heard about the Manchester
attack my daughter ariana grande is her
favorite singer if it was in London this
concert my daughter would have been in
that concert it's her favorite singer I
mean mother is 9 she would have been
there this is one of the reasons why I
have not slept I don't even know how to
I don't know where to begin
ariana grande is back in the United
States after last night's horrific
attack in the UK she landed in Florida
this afternoon on the same private jet
used by Taylor Swift the singer was
greeted by loved ones and comforted by
boyfriend Mac Miller her manager Scooter
Braun told CBS News her mental state
right now is not good at all and she has
devastated over the news eg senior news
editor Jennifer perros is at the
Manchester Arena tonight vigils are
being held all over England as well as
several right here in Manchester as for
ariana grande as I'm sure you can
imagine she is not expected to go
through her shows in London on Thursday
and Friday evening the attack killed 22
people including an eight-year-old girl
this morning I spoke to several
survivors who described the mass panic
after the explosion I was actually going
to die I was so scared were people
running as fast as they possibly could
in panic into in terror just
to get out crying there was there was
mothers carrying children over their
shoulders they could to get these people
out a source close to ariana grande
tells ad that the singer's mother Joan
assured a few fans backstage with her
after the explosion to make sure they
were out of harm's way the other angle
that everyone is talking about today is
security Michelle Turner is in New York
City with more on that Michelle well
Jenn I am here at Madison Square Garden
this is New York's biggest indoor arena
it seats about 20,000 people and it is
similar to Manchester Arena in the fact
that it has subway and rail lines here
at Penn Station running underneath the
building before you pass through
security that's where the attack can
happen so now they have to shore that up
so what's being done today
the NYPD did release what are called
Hercules teams which is an elite heavily
armed semi tactical unit which is part
of the department's counterterrorism
Bureau are you adding security on here
right now absolutely the police officers
with heavy weaponry
we have canine dogs we have New York
State Troopers around this venue and all
across the u.s. today from concerts to
hockey games security is being beefed up
the weekend is still performing tonight
in the Chicago area at Allstate Arena
now that venue tells et they met with
police and quote everyone will go
through metal detectors
there will be pat downs and a bomb
sniffing dog are these fans are my fans
and my fans are Ari's fans and like
we're just all loving on each other and
we should just stay loving on each other
Katie I just sat down with Elvis Duran
in the morning to the greatest thing
that we can do now is just unite as
people what happened last night gives us
all the more reason why we need to have
big fun concerts solutely
well said Katie another star expressing
his emotion British born James Corden he
ended his Late Late Show last night with
a very special message it shocks me
every time we hear this sort of news
that attacks like this can happen but
especially when there will be so many
children
[Music]